[Music]
today we're going to talk about
Claudette Colvin gets wet in Montgomery
Alabama in 1955 a young black woman
became the first person who was arrested
for not giving up her seat to a white
lady on the bus that young woman's name
is Claudette Colvin Claudette Colvin is
a fifteen-year-old bespectacled teenager
hello let me say bespectacled teenager
it's a hard word bespectacled she takes
the bus home from school so her friends
are like hurry we're having a fun trip
to home Oh white lady a white lady gets
on the bus the white lady is like hey
you guys have to move because I'm white
Claudette's friends leave but Claudette
stays and it's like you know what I paid
my fare the same as this white lady paid
her fare so quite as like you I'm
sitting have a seat white ladies like a
lot of a seat the bus sir I was like I'm
gonna get the cops so the cops are like
move Plata's like I should not be moved
and they dragged her off the bus the
only thing she knows to do is to go it's
my constitutional right and they're like
its 1955 and we don't have to do so you
caught us like 1955 but it was there a
verb so wait what I was just saying
though
the n-double-a-cp is flooded with
letters and Claudette Colvin is so brave
she's wonderful and the person reads
these letters the Secretary of the
n-double a-c-p Rosa Parks Rosa Parks
goes to Claudette Colvin's house and is
like credit you're the funnest like no
I'm the one who got my ass dragged to
jail and that's what they really connect
and become friends
so whenever she's at an N double ACP
meaning she spends the night at Rosa
Parks's house and Rosa Parks is like you
know what you're great quite a Koval's
like you're great they really connect
tiny bases and Edie Nixon the president
of their local chapter of the n-double
a-c-p is like we
need to start a bus boycott in this bus
boycott who will start a revolution we
should use Claudette Colvin's arrest as
a reason to boycott the buses people get
behind her but then they were like oh
but not white people because she has
darker skin and we can't have a
fifteen-year-old as the face of the
anti-segregation movement but we can't
have Rosa Parks as the face of this
movement so it's at that time that Rosa
Parks sits down in the white section of
the bus and gets taken off to jail but
she had to act like oh I was just tired
aren't I not threatening white people
and then white people were like oh she's
just tired we're eating this up
[Music]
our story starts and Argon's a little
rag to be specific it's 1957 the Supreme
Court has just ruled in the case of
brown versus the Board of Education that
separate is not equal so their local
n-double-a-cp went out to the black
community and found nine kids to go to
Central High School the premier High
School in Little Rock Arkansas so these
kids are like we are the Little Rock
Nine we are taking nine visions of black
excellence we will go to school and will
change the world
it'll be great so then the governor of
Arkansas Orval Faubus finds out that
these kids are planning to integrate and
this bitch Orville fart bus you can
fight all you want for bus anyway
horrible fart bus was like hey if these
kids integrate the streets will run red
with blood fart bus is bitch the kids
show up to school on September 4th 1957
the first day of school the senior in
the group of the Little Rock Nine is
Ernest green and he is like oh my gosh
there is an ass load of angry white
people this angry white mob was like we
don't like you you need to go away we
are going to beat you up and hang you
from the tree
[Music]
meanwhile on the other side of school
Elizabeth Eckford the ninth of the
Little Rock Nine is like a I'm here
all by myself oh my god there's a huge
mob of white people visit
terrifying it they're yelling and they
have signs in there shouting and
they are like hey your way I mean I'm
like it did you're black so that means I
don't like you so she gathers herself
and this girl is g-dub face
stone cold and walking through these
people who wanna pick her up and break
her in two just walking through like a G
and she sees the Arkansas National Guard
they must be here to help me she thinks
she quickened her pace and she goes hey
this one's gonna kill me baby and they
like block her entrance they are letting
other white students in what is the deal
you're the national guard if
anybody needs to be guarded as me here
now
so she leaves school she sits down at
the bus stop and the white people are
surrounding her anew it we don't like
you you are poopy she waits several
minutes for the bus the bus pulls up and
she is like thank God I can finally get
out of here this isn't the last I will
see of you but also can I
just get a education
[Music]
so dr. King is using the 16th Street
Baptist Church to try to organize
protests and mindil came in like you
know threat of it stop us to do
something and the adults were like
listen it's not that we don't agree with
you but at the end of the day I still
have to put food on the table and pay
the rent in this whole I don't want them
burning crosses on my lawn or any
like that so look bitches not safe we
can't do this
and dr. King was like if we can't enact
change in Birmingham we can't do it
anywhere who can join in the protests
and get arrested with us and he was sort
of shocked to see Glenn Ellen Sanders
and her sisters get up and say you know
what we'll do it we will do something
about this and then more and more kids
stood up to violence here they decided
to mobilize so that's exactly what they
did they went back to school like listen
we know y'all are sick of the racism and
there's something we can actually do
about it
and on May 2nd they the protest went
down administrators started locking the
doors to keep them from getting out the
kids were just straight up jump out the
window like bitch and I don't keep us
here over a thousand kids left school to
go to Kelly Ingram Park to protest but
then we'll Connor head of the Birmingham
Police Department it's like okay we all
black asses can go to jail so they
started carding these kids off by the
dozens and over a thousand kids were
arrested on that first day which is
insane after a few days of protest the
Birmingham jail with Thole overcrowding
and
as more kids are arrested others come
back now to take up their place but on
May 5th that was what she got really
real cool Bull Connor was looking at
hundreds of black kids standing up to
his his like let's bring out
the hoses these are high pressure knock
you the water hoses but the kids
realized their strength in numbers and
togetherness matters so those kids
linked hands and said not today
bitch not today so Bull Connor decides
okay release the k-9 units so that the
dogs could these kids up and at this
point there were news crews there that
caught the entire situation on camera
and these are now some of the most
infamous shots of the civil rights
movement and after people saw children
on international TV being sprayed with
hoses and attacked by dogs a mind shift
occurred and after eight solid days of
protests President Kennedy felt
motivated to come out and say you know
what I didn't want to say it before
because of the southern way of odors but
their mothers are racist so it's time to
just be really the that you are
going out here and doing to people in my
name is not the okay
oh man I love drinking so anyway who was
I talking about the kids well after the
success of the Birmingham Children's
March dr. King decided to ride that
momentum and he gave his I have a dream
speech Bull Connor was fired and the
Civil Rights Act was passed within a
year of all that so his monumental that
Gwendolyn Sanders and these kids weren't
willing to say this is not a
game and you won't treat us in our
people this way because we're here and
this is what's going on and it's time
for us to stand up to and so I don't
have to worry about that sort of thing
the way those kids even did or their
parents even did no I don't take that
for granted cheers as a kid you see the
kids
you